like it's really a bit of an institution
in Paris we're really lucky because
they've allowed us to have a sneak peek
behind the scenes we will do our next
screening of National Theatre live
productions at the Bell back in two
weeks time so we're really excited to go
and have a look inside
I could definitely spend to her sitting
Missy drawn into a completely different
world a film
[Music]
anything like China with just on in
there
latex a power hope there's no shocks
putting on ski ki dhaara very sneaky
we're producing him out there's an it
heart you know Sharon you
okay so we're really behind the scenes
here we're in the projection booth of
the cinema come this way with me
he seems every on 52 decent low by the
city's vessels Jackson Virginia should
be a resume is a green Santos and 420
home policy also Mission Control
resolute oh this is deeper no cops no
noisy calm calm if we just go down to
the end of the corridor here we can see
some of the photographs that were taken
back in the day when the bad back was
really doing loads of having ten years
with people for
the French cinema seeing people like
Brigitte Bardot island alone all these
very glamorous stars made of kiss there
as well
Alain Delon my aunty had a massive crush
on him and came back in history their
own I hope it's good only single I don't
know go on Sarah see a nice pair of
Anton Kolev and hydro fuel efficient
sails into life Twelfth Night
let me do
[Music]